is the m2 macbook pros slow ssds a big
deal in the real world well today i will
show you guys the proof and honestly i
didn't expect it to be this much of a
difference for those that use their
macbook pro for professional uses or
even semi-pro i was quite surprised now
on friday we got the brand new m2
macbook pro and we started testing it
out we are super excited and then we ran
into an issue when we ran the black
magic disc speed test we saw that it was
going really slow for some reason it did
not make sense and then we opened up the
back covers to find that there is only
one nand chip for the ssd storage
instead of two like with the m1 macbook
pro that came out a year and a half ago
and that explained it when you have half
the chips the speed goes down and our
write speed was 1400 instead of 2200 so
that's gonna slow things down but with
that the read speed was half the
performance slightly less than half
when do we ever have where a new laptop
literally has speeds that are half
compared to the previous version that
was crazy now with that the new dell xps
13 which we're going to be doing a
comparison with against the m2 macbook
pro that thing has blazing fast ssds
incredible pc express 4.0 which apple is
not even putting them in here but then
we get this with the base model now some
people online said that this is not a
big deal that's still fast enough so we
wanted to see for ourselves does it
really make a big difference now
transferring is one thing and i'll show
you guys the performance difference but
also with that when you're opening up
different web browsing tasks you have
one or two applications open and the ram
eight gigs of ram fills up well that
means that it has to use the ssd as ram
for swap and here is the difference in
performance i have 50 42 megapixel
images opened right here with
corrections and we ran this test on
friday so now that we have some
different things open i'm going to run
it again now before i run it i want to
show you guys what else i have open so i
have photoshop right here let's press in
and in here i have nine images open so
nothing crazy no effects or anything
else and right there you guys saw
that the m1 macbook pro actually loaded
that up faster now why could it do that
when the single core score is way
quicker in the m2 the fastest than any
laptop multi-core and then graphics is
faster well it's because we have the
base model and ssds are much slower and
just to prove to you guys here we have
the m1
and the m2 now i also want to mention
that these base models sell like
hotcakes not only are they kept in stock
everywhere a bunch of websites online
that sell them the apple store best buy
it's just a great price point so that's
why we were so happy with the m1 macbook
air and m2 macbook air because they
performed incredibly let's try it one
more time with the first image here
bam once again i mean that's not a huge
difference but this is just opening up
an image now here's google chrome you
guys can see that i don't have an insane
amount of tabs open and we've done some
ram comparisons where we went all out
for pro apps uh crazy stuff this ain't
it a lot of you guys have more of tabs
open than this let's open up youtube
let's go to ign
right there you guys saw that the m1 is
snappier which it shouldn't be how about
my google drive
once again a little bit quicker we'll do
one more
there you go now this is where it's just
weird that the m1 feels faster now let's
just go ahead and export our 50 images
and that was weird there because i'm
pretty sure i clicked the lightroom here
first and then i clicked it here this
one loaded up quicker anyway so let's
export now as you guys could see the m1
is already
rolling the m2 is just starting up now
this will start to catch up a bit i
actually ran this test before making
this video i just want to see for myself
does the ssd really matter and then once
i start seeing results like this i'm
like man it definitely does matter now
the results are pretty shocking here's
the first results from friday we have
two minutes and i believe it was two
minutes and 18 seconds and then once we
have a couple pro apps open we're
running an export and some tabs the m1
takes 3 minutes and 36 seconds so you
guys see it definitely gets lower
whereas the m2 took 4 minutes and 12
seconds so it gets slower than the m1
and now we're running a photo merge in
photoshop now i don't know what the
results are going to be here
i did not test this before when i was
just testing for myself but we'll see
what happens all right the m1 is done
and we have to wait for the m2 all right
so for some reason it crashed it was
there right at the end so the m1 took 50
seconds exactly whereas the m2 took a
minute and 21 seconds it was right there
at the end we're supposed to pop it open
and it just crashed on me
um i didn't think this would be as
difficult of a test uh maybe it is more
ram dependent and i want to make it
clear that if you don't push your system
very hard you might not care about this
it won't make a difference if for
example you have five tabs open and
maybe photoshop open you know but a lot
of people
if they're buying a pro machine they
want to be able to do more multitasking
and more professional tasks so in that
case you probably should go for the m2
macbook air even more so now than before
let's do a few more tests i'm going to
do a transfer test and export a video
now i also noticed a difference in
snappiness even for the ui going through
the file menu just general kind of
slowness and stuttering and that's what
made the m1 so good and now we know that
it wasn't only because of the apple
silicon and all the other great things
but also because they put in really fast
ssds even for the base model i'm gonna
go ahead and quit photoshop here and
let's go ahead and open up final cut pro
we have a five minute project opened up
right here with film grain applied and a
couple luts for color correction which
is standard for a lot of people and
let's hit export now we did this exact
test on friday and the m2 beat out the
m1 by two seconds taking two minutes and
23 seconds instead of two minutes and 25
seconds this time the m1 took 3 minutes
and 36 seconds whereas the m2 took four
minutes and 49 seconds and that just
shows you the difference that you could
get now what i'm going to do right now
is close down lightroom we had photoshop
closed before we opened the final cut i
also closed out some tabs and let's see
what we get this time okay they started
out pretty much neck and neck the m1 was
one percent above and now it's taking
the lead a little bit more so all right
the m1 is almost done 99
we're 87
on the m2 and bam we are done on the m2
the m1 took two minutes and 40 seconds
so just slightly slower than when we
just had final cut open and then the m2
took three minutes and three
seconds now we still have a bunch of
tabs open i have my google drive i just
closed a few of them there
that i had just random safari open so
let's check this out you guys could see
i don't have uh lightroom open anymore
photoshop open
here are my tabs right here we have one
video playing in the background
oftentimes i'll have music or something
else i have my google drive here and you
know just some regular tabs
and then let's go ahead and open up our
activity monitor and see
what it looks like so
interestingly
wow okay they're running a little bit
differently
so here we have both of eight gigs of
ram memory used 7.19 gigs compared to
6.5
and that's because the m1 model is using
more swap i don't know if there's more
background tasks open i mean this is an
older machine
and as far as cache it also has more
cache or maybe the m2 tries to not use
swap as much because it knows as slower
as disease i have no idea i'm not an
engineer with ssds but you guys see the
memory pressure right here looks very
similar but you guys see the performance
difference and now let's go ahead and
quit final cut and we are going to do a
transfer speed test i'm also closing a
few of these tabs right here so we have
a little bit less so i'm using my highly
recommended sabrand external drive it is
over thunderbolt but it does not hit
2900 like the m1 macbook pro can so part
of this test will be limited just by the
speed itself but that doesn't matter
this is real world and i have a 35
gigabyte file here that i will be
transferring so it started out pretty
quick and then it slowed down quite a
bit
now
uh we have plenty of space on this ssd
but what i'm wondering
is what about the slc cache we've talked
about this before a lot of ssds have
really fast speeds but then after you
transfer a certain amount it slows down
because they're slower chips that just
have one portion that is quick
we don't know what kind of ssd is in
here and now that after 20 gigs we
slowed down there are ssds after 20 gigs
it starts slowing down
that's what i'm curious about because
it's writing way slower now so that took
us a minute and 25 seconds to transfer
and now transferring back to the ssd all
right that's going way faster when
you're transferring from the ssd to
something else you don't have the soc
cache limit except for unless your
external drive has one which this one is
very good which is why we highly
recommend it we'll link it down in the
description below so that took 58
seconds to transfer it also slowed down
a bit at the end and now the same file
with the m1 macbook pro with the faster
ssds all right wow this thing is
speeding through it
still going quick okay guys you saw that
for yourselves 34 seconds and then going
back that took 45 seconds so quicker
than the m2 macbook but not by a huge
amount because um this ssd is limiting
it which of course this ssds in here are
faster than most external even
thunderbolt ones so there you guys go i
was quite surprised when i wanted to
test this out for myself to see if it
really does make a big difference
because people are saying no it doesn't
really matter that much that's fast
enough i was like surely it has to with
swap
because there should be some
responsiveness differences and maybe if
you're multitasking so i started
checking it out for myself and i just
had to share with you guys now
i would just say
it's still a good system but if you're
buying one make sure you get at least
512 gigabytes which is going to cost you
an extra 200
not even for the capacity but just to
get the same speed of ssds that you got
last year with the base m1 macbook pro
or upgrade to 16 gigabytes of ram to
make sure that you don't go into that
swap very often or realistically both
but then at that point if you're
upgrading both you're not far away from
a 14-inch macbook pro especially if you
get one at a discount which you can get
on amazon we'll link it down below
that's a much better machine so i think
that's the video we're going to do next
we're going to compare the 14 inch real
world performance compared to
the 13 inch macbook pro so if you guys
want to see that make sure you click
that circle above check out one of those
great videos over there this max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]